Tim Ferriss: Hello, boys and girls, ladies
and germs.
This is Tim Ferriss.
Welcome to another episode of The Tim Ferriss
Show.
I'm going to hop straight into the guest because
I have so many questions I would like to ask.
My guest today is Jonathan Haidt, spelled
H-A-I-D-T.
You can find him on Twitter @jonhaidt.
He's a social psychologist at New York University's
Stern School of Business.
Jonathan received his PhD from the University
of Pennsylvania in 1992.
His research examines the intuitive foundations
of morality in how morality varies across
cultural and political divisions.
He is the author of The Happiness Hypothesis
and the New York Times bestsellers The Righteous
Mind and The Coddling of the American Mind
(with Greg Lukianoff).
He has given four TED Talks and in 2019 he
was inducted into the American Academy of
Arts and Sciences.
Since 2018, Jonathan has been studying the
contributions of social media to the decline
of teen mental health and the rise of political
dysfunction.
He is currently writing two books: Kids in
Space: Why Teen Mental Health Is Collapsing
and Life after Babel — great title, also.
Life after Babel: Adapting to a World We Can
No Longer Share.
You can find him at jonathanhaidt.com and
on Twitter once again @jonhaidt.
Jon, nice to see you.
Thanks for making the time.
Jonathan Haidt: Oh, my pleasure, Tim.
Very nice to meet you.
Tim Ferriss: I thought we would begin with
influences.
How your personality, how your thinking has
taken shape and I wanted to begin with the
name Richard Shweder.
Could you please explain who Richard is and
how he factors into your life story?
Jonathan Haidt: I have many mentors and sometimes
I do what I call the gratitude parade in my
head and people flash past and there's a string
of mentors.
Rick Shweder is the biggest on who I am, and
what I've written.
Rick Shweder is a cultural anthropologist
at the University of Chicago and when I wrote
my dissertation at Penn, I wrote it on a debate
that he was having with some other people
who study morality who were saying that morality
is always about harm, rights, and justice.
Shweder said, "Well yeah, where you live in
Cambridge, Massachusetts it is, but around
the world the moral domain is much broader
and there's the ethics of community, ethics
of divinity."
I planned a study to pit the two theories
against each other and I did a study in Brazil
and the US across social classes and Shweder's
predictions really came out beautifully.
I found big cultural variation, especially
social class variation in morality.
In part because of that I was able to get
a postdoc doing research with him.
For two years after my PhD, I spent at the
University of Chicago and during that time
I got a fellowship to go to India for three
months where Shweder worked in Bhubaneswar
in the state of Odisha, India.
That period, that year, 1993, I hope that's
a year that we'll come back to a couple times
during this conversation because that is the
pivotal year in my life when my mind was blown
in many ways.
One of which was that I was reading Buddhism
and Hinduism and then I spent three months
in India and it really was welcome to my world
and my way of thinking because Shweder is
the most brilliant, iconoclastic, thinking
for himself, perverse in the most wonderful
way, intellectual I've ever met.
That's the beginning of who Rick Shweder is.
Tim Ferriss: Perverse intellectuals.
That might be the headline of this episode.
We are going to come back to 1993.
We're definitely going to come back to Bhubaneswar.
I was wondering how to pronounce that.
I'm glad you gave me the layup in advance.
I'd like to visit a motto, I believe.
You can't believe everything you read on the
internet, but hopefully The Atlantic is reliable
in this respect.
A motto of Rick's that I'd like to unpack,
which is, "If someone asserts it, try denying
it and see if that makes sense.
If someone denies it, try asserting it and
see if that makes sense."
Jonathan Haidt: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: Could you explain what this means?
Tim Ferriss: And maybe give an example of
how he used it or would encourage students
to use it.
Jonathan Haidt: It comes from, I think a brother-in-law
of Rick's who is a dermatologist.
The dermatologist once said to him, "Oh, dermatology
is easy.
Just follow this rule.
If it's dry, make it wet.
If it's wet, make it dry."
Rick being, again, this perversity, he takes
that rule and that was sort of the way he
ran his intellectual life.
When I went to Chicago, it's like the most
intense intellectual square mile in the country.
You'd be in these seminars with all these
Nobel Prize-winning economists and people
and someone would say something and Rick would
turn it around and say, "Is the opposite true?"
Then he would ask, "Well isn't also the opposite
of what you're saying true?"
Then you'd have to think, wait, actually,
yeah, that is too, sometimes.
What I take from it is we have such pressures
to fall into line with our team to go with
what the dominant view is.
If you do that, you're going to end up being
kind of a hack.
You're going to end up being like everyone
else.
If you just automatically question things,
not to be a jerk, now you could do it and
be a jerk.
If you just question it just with pure intellectual
curiosity, is it true if we turn it around?
Usually it's not, but often it is.
That's how you get new insights.
If you just have that as a habit, yeah, this
is definitely good advice for anyone in a
creative industry or in the academic world.
Just try turning things around.
Tim Ferriss: How would, just as an example,
Rick potentially use this in anthropology?
It might have been a broader guiding tenet
of his thinking that applied to much more
outside of his sort of declared field of expertise.
Is there an example you might give for how
that would fit into anthropology or the type
of research that you were doing at the time?
Jonathan Haidt: So one pops to mind, but it's
so offensive that I have to start with something
else, because otherwise I'll lose your listeners.
Tim Ferriss: You have to warm up the listening
hamstrings.
Jonathan Haidt: Just one example is he was
in a discussion with some psychologist because
he's an anthropologist but he's in cultural
psychology.
I'm a psychologist.
He's in a discussion with some psychologists
and they were saying, "Well, I mean, we have
experimental evidence on this and that's just
so much more reliable than ethnography.
I mean ethnography, an anthropologist goes
someplace and they take notes and they report,
but that's just one person's view.
Experimental evidence is just much more reliable."
He turns around and he says, "Oh, really?
Well, let's see.
Then you look at experiments that often don't
replicate.
Then you look at anthropological accounts
where often multiple anthropologists will
go someplace and they will find the same thing."
The point is just you automatically assume,
well, of course experiments with numbers and
careful procedures are better.
He just sort of turns it around and says,
"Well, actually, maybe not."
Okay.
That's the easy one.
I hope listeners are with me on that.
Here's the hard one, just about the most offensive
cultural practice in the world for anthropologists
and enlightened people is called FGM.
Now that stands for female genital mutilation
and anthropologists and Progressives are so
tolerant, so quick to say, "Let's not condemn
other cultures.
Let's look at it from their point of view."
On this issue they don't.
What Rick was doing was saying, "In the societies
where they do this, let's try to understand
what they're doing."
He's totally open to the fact that sometimes
it really is a horrible operation that deprives
the woman of sexuality.
There are such a range of practices, but if
you simply say any modification on a female
should be punishable by time in jail, well
then what happens is you have a variety of
African and Islamic immigrant groups in the
US and Canada where the mothers are put in
jail.
Rick says,"Well, let's question this.
Once you see what they're doing, and sometimes
it's much more equivalent to male circumcision,
which is common around the world."
Anyway, actually, no, your listeners probably
aren't going to bolt just because of that.
I might get in trouble in other parts of the
academic world.
Tim Ferriss: If they bolt just because of
that, then honestly this is culling of the
herd because let me, before you continue,
please hold your place, bookmark.
Folks, part of the reason I wanted to have
Jon on, and I respect the work that he does,
is that I believe using this type of examination
and self-examination, you become more antifragile
and you can also see through the veil of your
own conditioning in a more effective way.
You can examine your thinking and your assumptions
vis-à-vis the language you use, the language
you've absorbed, the labels that are your
defaults, et cetera.
I think this makes you a better, more effective,
and hopefully, ultimately, happier person
who's a better contributor to society.
There's my sales pitch.
Jonathan Haidt: Wow, perfect.
We're done here.
You said it.
That's exactly right.
That's why I'm so grateful to Rick.
Because if you develop this as a habit, you
become more intellectually antifragile, which
we'll get to.
I hope it helps you step out of your team.
It helps you think independently and you can
see that your team does a lot of stupid things.
Every team does.
Yes, what you said.
Tim Ferriss: What I said.
All right.
Then we flash back to 1993, and I would love
to revisit, I'm going to write this down sort
of moral relativism and how we might think
about that and how we either embrace that
or develop an awareness around it.
Let's postpone 1993 and actually just tackle
this right now.
There are a number of books I read a long
time ago when I was part of something called
the Henry Crown Fellowship at the Aspen Institute.
One, I am, I want to say it was, I want to
say H.G. Wells (George Orwell, Ed.), but I
don't think that is right, who wrote an essay
called "Shooting [an] Elephant" or something
along these lines.
You may actually be able to track back the
proper author of this, but it spoke of sort
of social pressures and during British colonialism,
this series of events that led to someone
feeling like he needed to shoot an elephant
that was causing all this ruckus in a village
even though he didn't want to.
That was describing social pressures and how
those can lead to actions that we find immoral
or reprehensible ourselves.
Putting that aside, that's just an example.
We also read a lot about morality, not in
a structured way, I think, that would maybe
stand toe to toe with the type of research
you do in any way.
But reading various accounts of people succumbing
to moral relativism where everything is okay
because it's in a different culture, it's
in a different time.
How would you suggest people think about that?
Because on one hand, yeah, I think that's
dangerous.
On the other hand there's, there's so much
intolerance, masquerading as tolerance and
there's so many issues that I'm sure we'll
get into.
Just with the subject of moral relativism,
how do you think about that?
Jonathan Haidt: This is a great topic to tackle
in a longer discussion.
Because it's one of the oldest questions in
philosophy, it's an important one and it takes
a little doing.
There are a lot of intellectual puzzles where
we just naturally think about it on a single
dimension or as a binary.
If you kind of break it up into multiple dimensions,
then you see solutions.
The typical way of thinking about this is
there is morality real?
Is it a real thing, the laws of physics such
that if people are behaving contrary to it,
they're wrong even if they don't know it.
Or is morality just Herodotus and ancient
Greeks, they saw this, "Well, in this country
they kill their parents when they get old,
and in this country they eat pigs," and they
could see that practices differed.
Well maybe it's just like language, it's just
like whatever happens in your culture, well
that's what's grammatical.
What I learned in part from Shweder and also
reading a lot of philosophy, some of which
he guided me to, was I'll put out a couple
of concepts.
The first is moral monism versus moral pluralism.
The question isn't, "Is there moral truth
or not?"
It's, "Is there one moral truth or multiple?"
Once you do that, now you've loosened things
up.
Because a hallmark of my work, and this is
where I departed from Rick a bit, is I've
always been very influenced by evolutionary
psychology as well as anthropology.
We are evolved creatures, we are homo sapiens
and we are all homo sapiens and we are primates
and we have a lot in common with chimpanzees
and bonobos.
That's the evolutionary side.
Then there's also the anthropology, we vary.
When you look around the world, you don't
find infinite variation, you find a few major
patterns.
A wonderful book, Dancing in the Streets:
A History of Collective Joy by Barbara Ehrenreich.
She says, when the European explorers went
out and the 16th, 17th century, they found
wherever they went, people danced around campfires,
had rituals that bonded the group together,
they often used psychedelic substances, they
had beat heavy music.
This is human nature, but feudal systems are
also pretty common.
There are a few major patterns.
One possibility is there's not just one way
of doing things, but it's not anything goes.
It's that there are several different sort
of grammatical human forms.
This actually became the basis of my major
work in psychology, which is moral foundation's
theory, which is my effort to say what are
the taste buds of the moral sense?
Because cuisine varies around the world.
You wouldn't say that the French are wrong
if they don't cook like the Vietnamese.
I think you could say that the French and
the Vietnamese are both much better cooks
than the English, or at least they were historically.
There is some truth.
It's not that anything goes, there is some
truth.
Here's where we're bringing the second kind
of abstract but really powerful concept, which
is anthropocentric truth.
That means something can be true relative
to humans, to who we are.
If intelligent aliens come to our solar system,
they will find that the Earth is the third
planet from the Sun.
That was true before we existed, and it'll
be true long after we're gone.
They would find that gold is a better conductor
of electricity than aluminum.
That was true before we were here.
It'll be true.
Those are non-anthropocentric truths.
There's a fact and many people have been on
a quest to find what are the moral truths.
Sam Harris, who for a brief time was my intellectual
enemy, we kind of had a feud for a few years.
Now we're friends, we actually like each other
quite a lot.
We had kind of a feud over this because he
has a whole book about the landscape of morality
arguing that moral truths are like the truths
of chemistry.
I say no.
They are anthropocentric truths.
This is from a philosopher David Wiggins.
There are things that are true because of
the creatures we are.
There are things that are beautiful because
of our senses.
There are things that are, so Shakespeare
is a better writer than Kurt Vonnegut.
Now I love reading Kurt Vonnegut, I probably
enjoy it more than Shakespeare, but man, I
can see and almost everyone can, Shakespeare
is a complete genius at crafting words.
Now that's a fact.
If aliens come here from another planet, they're
not going to agree because it doesn't make
sense.
It wouldn't fit with their nature.
Anyway, so putting this all together, I think
what we can say is there are moral truths
and moral orders that are emergent.
I am not a relativist, I'm not a monist, I
am a moral pluralist.
There are multiple moral truths.
These truths are emergent from human nature
interacting as people interact in large in
societies.
Okay, wow.
I think I just did it.
Tim Ferriss: It was great.
I want to tag on a follow up, which is how
do you personally, and we're going to come
back to from feud to friends story because
I think that could be an instructive case
study plus, I'm just curious because I'm friends
with Sam also, who is a great, he's a very
formidable sparring partner.
Jonathan Haidt: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: When you look at global events,
how do you think about, personally, human
rights violations, what to accept, what to
oppose yourself as a pluralist?
I'm not saying that because I'm viewing myself
as the opposite of a pluralist.
I'm just curious how you personally think
about what you are proactively going to push
back against.
Doesn't need to be outside the US.
Jonathan Haidt: Because I'm an emergentist,
that is I believe that morals emerge as we
interact.
I don't think that 50,000 years ago, societies
were wrong in dividing labor between male
and female.
It's not like they were wrong and they should
have fixed it.
They should have had perfect — no.
As we now have modern societies with labor-saving
devices and you don't have to divide labor
between male and female, and there are other
ways to live.
Now any society that was to say, "Well, women
can't do certain things, only men can."
Well that would be wrong.
In a modern Western society, that would be
unethical.
That would be a violation of civil rights.
Now when we look at things like countries
in which the secret police grab people in
the night and take them away and torture and
kill them, you don't have to be a very advanced
society to realize that this is horrific,
this is wrong, this is brutality.
This is not justified by appeals to morals.
I once developed a kind of a three-part test.
Let me see if I can remember it.
Because what we want to do is we want to separate
things like veiling or things where they might
be broadly accepted in a culture, but we are
offended by them from things like chattel
slavery where some people accept it but the
victims of it didn't accept it.
I think we can point to things, it's often
tricky, but we can point to things where we
can say, we can criticize that practice and
that culture.
In extreme cases we might even say we should
try to undermine it or try to stop it.
We'd have to go case by case.
Widow burning in India and things like that,
which I think will clearly fall on one side.
That's how I would generally do it in the
abstract.
Now I think you asked me a slightly different
question, which was more like me personally,
not philosophically.
Right?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jonathan Haidt: A funny thing happened to
me as I've studied morality, which is that
I almost never get angry anymore.
Before 1993, I was a normal person who got
angry a lot and I'm pretty even-tempered.
It wasn't like I had anger problems.
I'd read the newspaper, I'd be angry at the
goddamn Ronald Reagan or whatever.
Or someone cuts me off or something's slow.
I was sort of quasi type A, this "pushy, smart
alec son of a bitch Jewish kid" is what my
neighbor once called me.
I used to be like that.
Then in 1993 I changed in part from, the key
thing there was actually taking LSD for the
first time while I was studying to go to India
and reading the Bhagavad Gita and reading
Hinduism and Hindu philosophy.
I was at 29 years old.
Here I am studying moral psychology and all
these things and in that year I kind of stepped
out of the matrix.
I kind of stepped out of the world that I
had been living in.
That is what allowed me, that year allowed
me to do the work I've done with the rest
of my life.
Which is saying, "You know what?
Let's try to understand Progressives and Conservatives
in their own terms."
Before then, I was just a standard, straight-issue,
Ivy League, Liberal, Progressive type person.
A roundabout way of answering your question
is I don't get mad.
I look at systems and I always think, "How
can we make them better?"
Systems that are producing terrible results
for human beings should be changed.
Actually I'll share, so one thing, this was
actually before my turning point.
In 1987, just before grad school, I traveled
alone across Eastern Europe.
That's why I went to Hungary, Romania, Bulgaria.
When I was in Romania where Ceaușescu was
the dictator, the people were literally cold
and dirty.
They literally did not have soap to clean
their clothes.
They did not have heat in the winter.
They were kept like animals and they behaved
like animals in some sense.
We try to get on a bus, there's so few buses,
people push and shove.
It didn't make me angry.
I was like, "Oh, my God."
Actually it did make me angry.
All of my feelings were against Ceaușescu.
I thought, "If I could kill this man with
my bare hands right now, I would do it and
I would love it."
It was so horrific to see what this man had
done to this society, him and his half million
secret policemen.
When he was shot in the mud in a courtyard
in 1989, I was thrilled.
I guess that's more of a direct answer to
your question.
If I see someone oppressing a whole society
or acting in that monstrous way, not for any
moral, morally legitimate reason, I think
we need to take action.
Tim Ferriss: Could you tell me more about
your LSD experience?
Why was that such a seemingly crucial ingredient
in that turning point or that period for you?
Jonathan Haidt: Yeah, because I know you've
had a fair amount of psychedelic coverage
on this podcast and I'm sure your listeners
will, many will be experienced or familiar
with it.
The turning point for me, it was June 11th,
1993, many other such experiences, one feels
reborn and you feel like you remember the
day, you remember exactly when it happened.
I was a postdoc in Chicago working with Shweder.
I went back to Philadelphia where I'd been
a grad student and where my ex-girlfriend,
we were still good friends, was there and
a lot of our friends and she got some acid
and we all did it.
It was my first time doing it at the age of
29.
The metaphor that I use in making sense of
it afterwards was it felt to me as though
I'd spent all my life living in this amazing
mansion with thousands of rooms.
I loved exploring this mansion and I loved
to travel and there were all these rooms to
explore and I thought I was seeing all this
stuff.
Then that night it was like God punched a
hole in the roof, reached in, picked me up,
took me out of the mansion, and took me around
the whole world and said, "You thought that
was the world?
No, this is the world.
It's beyond anything you can imagine."
Then he puts me back in the mansion, seals
up the roof and says, "Go on."
I don't mean literally God, I'm a Jewish atheist.
I don't believe literally in God.
These experiences have really helped me understand
the way we evolve from religion, the way almost
all societies have a way of using psychedelic
plants.
Oh, you interviewed Michael Pollan, so you
know what he said.
That experience certainly changed me as a
psychologist thinking about the human mind
and consciousness and self-transcendence and
all that.
It changed me as a human being because afterwards
it was like small things just don't matter.
It changes your perspective.
That's trite to say.
It also just helped me — what it did was
here at the same time I was reading the Bhagavad
Gita and in the Bhagavad Gita, there is a
specific scene, I talk about this in The Righteous
Mind or The Happiness Hypothesis.
There's a specific scene where Krishna gives
Arjuna a third eye to see the world as it
really is.
He's like gasping for breath.
He's like, he can't process it, but he comes
back and he wants to serve Krishna.
Now I didn't come back, I want to serve my
fellow man, but I felt like all my old pettiness,
all of that just sort of burned off.
I don't know, I just had a kind of an independence.
I'm not on a team, I just want to understand
what's happening.
Tim Ferriss: Did that then provide the fertile
ground that allowed you to learn?
I'm once again quoting from the Atlantic article,
the power of rituals and viewing a commitment
to religious purity as a way to knit communities
together.
In other words, without that experience, without
being plucked out of the mansion, do you think
you would've come to those conclusions on
your own in India, or were they mutually dependent
in a way?
Jonathan Haidt: I think they were mutually
dependent.
Yes.
I don't think I could have done it.
It would've been just more of a standard intellectual
experience.
This is interesting.
Let me write this down in my notebook.
Let me try to make sense of this.
Because the other piece we want to bring in
here is that in grad school I read Émile
Durkheim, the French sociologist and that
so, and really comes out in The Righteous
Mind like Rick Shweder and Émile Durkheim
and Charles Darwin.
Those are the three heroes of the book.
Those three men, their ideas just transform
my thinking.
So you put those all together in a 29-year-old
brain who's having a tremendously good time
at the University of Chicago and then going
to India and then as you're shaking it up,
you put in just a tiny little bit of LSD,
and boom, it comes out into a totally new
configuration.
That's kind of what happened to me in 1993.
Tim Ferriss: It is like the MSG of spiritual
multi-dimensional, just a little bit of pixie
dust of LSD.
Jonathan Haidt: Pixie dust, yes.
Yeah.
Well, you know, if you think about your frontal
cortex, it kind of locks down between 13 and
sort of mid to late twenties.
It's kind of locking down.
It's very open to change in your teen years,
but it kind of settles in by your late twenties.
As it's kind of setting that period of change,
had it been five or 10 years later, it might
not have had that much effect.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that would strike me as
a sort of critical formative window.
If you are able to slow the setting of the
concrete, or something along those lines,
metaphorically, then interesting things can
happen.
I will say, not to spend too much time on
the psychedelic component of this, but that
the loosening of self-identity, even at advanced
ages, let's just say in terminal cancer patients
are suffering from end-of-life anxiety.
The ability, and there's some evidence to
suggest, although I think it's simplistic,
that the downregulation of the default mode
network helps to inhibit self-referential
thinking and that type of executive function.
Therefore people experience this ego dissolution
or ego death.
Even in a less extreme instance of that, it
frees you from the constructs that have been
the lenses you've always worn but not realized
you've been wearing.
That's right to that extent, I do think it
allows you to see something like, for instance,
these behaviors and beliefs in India with
a very different set of eyes than would otherwise
be possible.
1993, I must say, just as coincidence, 1992
to 1993 was also the year that probably most
dramatically changed my life.
We were having, so how's that transformative
experiences in the same 12-month period.
Jonathan Haidt: The same time.
Tim Ferriss: It was my first time overseas
and I landed in Japan as an exchange student
going to a Japanese school living with Japanese
families for a year.
That broke open my mind in such an incredibly,
at points difficult ways, but in such a beautifully
profound and productive way because it forced
me to question what it meant to do things
the right way.
It was my first time being in a country where
people drove on the opposite side of the street.
It was my first time being anywhere where
the entire family shared the bath, didn't
change the water, and you had to clean yourself
beforehand.
The examples just where they cool their food
by slurping it in with great noise as opposed
to blowing on it with exhales.
It was like this Alice in Wonderland, topsy-turvy
upside down world for me.
I realized, oh, wow, all these things that
I have assumed are just the way things are
done, I don't want to say arbitrary, but they're
social conventions.
These are cultural emergent patterns.
They're not laws of physics.
During that same year, I also really, I think,
unlocked my ability to start to ask at least
questions about my assumptions.
Right?
"Well, is that really true?
Do we really have to do that?"
Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: "Is this really how it works?"
Even the structure of thought is mirrored
in language.
I mean, Japanese is very, very different.
Instead of being subject verb object, "I eat
the apple," "I the apple eat," "I to school
go," that type of thing.
It was a very productive year.
I want to come to a passing —
Jonathan Haidt: Wait, hold on a second.
I just want to pick up on that for one moment.
I think you had your experience at a sort
of a more opportune age than mine.
I mean, mine worked out great, but you were
in college at the time.
You were a student.
Tim Ferriss: Actually, this was before Princeton.
This would've been high school.
This was age 15 to 16.
Jonathan Haidt: Okay.
Yeah.
All right.
There's research on how we create stories
about ourselves.
And our stories are wide open from about 14
or 15 is when it kind of opens up through
the mid to late twenties.
That's like the key period.
You had yours right at the beginning of that
and listening to you, because I think so much
about Left-Right differences, there's research
that foreign travel makes people more Progressive,
more Liberal because you see how things can
be different.
Did it have that effect on you?
Were you Progressive or Liberal at the time?
Did it change your politics at all?
Tim Ferriss: I am grateful.
Very, very grateful.
I don't want to throw either of my parents
under the bus, but my dad was very vocal about
various political stuff and I completely turned
off that listening function.
So I did not, this is going to be embarrassing
perhaps to admit, but I effectively paid little
to no attention to politics until perhaps
10 years ago.
So I didn't identify politically at all.
I was really issue by issue, if they came
up.
If it was something that affected me or that
I thought I might want to change, that was
the extent of my radar pickup.
I will say that in retrospect, looking at
my experience, probably also given the way
that Japanese society is structured and the
availability of healthcare and this, that,
and the other thing, that many of those issues
would probably be associated with a Left-leaning,
Progressive mindset, I suppose.
I would have to imagine that to be the case.
I don't see how it would go the other way
because I wasn't — even though in Japan
there is some pretty crazy nationalism and
super hardcore, I suppose, Right-extreme stuff,
I was not exposed to that.
Jonathan Haidt: Right.
Okay.
Because the thought, the idea that I was just
developing from what you were saying was this,
I've long thought, since I wrote The Righteous
Mind, and since I really tried to understand
Conservatism and Libertarians and really got
the wisdom from those traditions, as well
as the Progressive or Liberal tradition, and
I've really come to see that a functioning
society, it needs a Progressive wing pushing
for change and it needs a Conservative wing
saying, "Slow down," tapping on the brakes.
William F. Buckley stands athwart history,
yelling, "Stop."
You need both in a healthy society.
We don't have that now.
Our Left is not Liberal.
Our Right is not Conservative.
We're a mess.
But societies need those two impulses.
And just from when you were saying, it didn't
occur to me, it's like, actually, I wonder
if in a person's development you need both
of those.
That is, early on you need to open up and
travel and see the world and question things.
But if you stay that way the rest of your
life, you might be dysfunctional.
Because there's interesting research showing
that it's not age that makes people become
more Conservative.
It's having children or starting a business
or taking on responsibility.
Once you take on some responsibility, you
realize, "You know what?
We actually need some rules here.
There has to be some authority or some hierarchy.
There have to be punishments for cheating."
So in the course of a human life, maybe there's
the opening up travel period and then the
like, okay, you've got all this stuff in your
head, now you have to apply it.
You have to focus and you have to be conscientious.
All right, just a thought.
Keep going.
Tim Ferriss: I like that idea.
I've never thought of it that way.
I would also say Japan deeply resonated with
me on a lot of levels that my experience in
the United States did not.
The cleanliness, the obsessive compulsive
focus on detail, just the level of meticulous
attention to the most minute of details, which
can be crippling.
It's not all upside, but that so deeply, to
me, felt like a warm bath for maybe my predispositions
or my neurosis, that it felt like a rebirth
of sorts.
I would have friends who would say, "[foreign
language]."
They would just be like, "You're not American.
I don't get it.
You're white and you look like what you look
like, but you're more Japanese than I am."
They would make these jokes because it came
so easily to me culturally in a way to whatever
extent that makes any sense, there was that.
I did want to ask you about your comment,
the label you used of Jewish atheist.
So "I am a Jewish atheist," and I want to
provide some context for this, which is Paul
Graham, who's famous for co-founding Y Combinator,
had a tweet, I think it was actually in one
of his essays also, along the lines of, "The
more labels you apply to yourself, the stupider
you become."
Something like that.
I'm paraphrasing it, but, be careful what
the labels that you use.
I'm not forcing that on you, but I'm curious
to know the thinking behind Jewish atheist.
I'm friends with a writer named A.J.
Jacobs, who said —
Jonathan Haidt: Oh, yeah.
I love A.J.
Yeah.
One of the funniest writers around.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, he's hilarious.
So he said something like, "I am to Jewish
what Olive Garden is to Italian," or something
like that, was his explanation —
Jonathan Haidt: Yeah, that's a [inaudible],
yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — when he wrote the book The
Year of Living Biblically, which is a fantastic,
fantastic book.
How do you think about being Jewish?
What does that mean to you?
Jonathan Haidt: If we're having this discussion
in the context of a Christian background culture,
Christianity is somewhat unusual, although
Islam is similar in making — it's all about
your relationship with God and faith.
And Judaism is a more ancient religion, and
it's very much about a story about a tribe,
a group, that has these ups and downs in history
and we're bound together.
Of course, God is a very, very important part
of the story, but as Jews have lived in different
cultures around the world, well that shapes
your identity and so you can be Jewish and
not believe in God, just like you can be Italian
and not be Catholic.
So as an ethnic group, as an identity, as
a culture, I'm Jewish, and I recognize the
influence of just the norms.
The argumentativeness.
And here we're talking Ashkenazi Jewish.
I should always be clear that Sephardic Jews
are different.
There are different kinds of Jews, but the
American Jewish experience is dominated by
the Ashkenazi, the Eastern European immigrants.
All four of my grandparents came here from
Russia, Poland, and Belarus around 1907 when
they were teenagers, roughly.
So, yeah, it's part of my — okay, so I was
about to say, it's part of my identity, and
I guess it is.
But I'm playing these days with the idea that
actually I'm an anti-identitarian.
I think part of what's wrong with the country
is that America, of all countries, needs to
be a melting pot.
We need to have a generally assimilationist
ethos.
And that worked so well for the Jews, the
Irish, the Italians, all the groups that came
through Ellis Island into an assimilationist,
20th century America.
It worked out fantastically well.
Anyway, we can follow that down in a moment,
the identitarianism, but I guess, so you can
be Jewish by identity and not believe in God.
In fact, I'd like to do this formally.
I always think if you ask a Christian, "Do
you believe in God?"
Usually, if they've identified as a Christian,
they're usually going to say, "Yes."
Okay, try asking that with 10 Jews.
Maybe one of them will say, "Yes," and maybe
two or three will say, "No."
And the rest will say, "Well, it depends.
Do you mean this?
Do you that?
Well, sort of, maybe."
So being Jewish is different religiously than
being Christian or Muslim.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
That makes sense.
That makes sense to me.
Do you, as an atheist, build in any rituals
or traditions from the Jewish lineage, let's
say?
Jonathan Haidt: Okay, so this helps me clarify,
atheist is not part of my identity.
I said I'm a Jewish atheist, but atheist is
not part of my identity.
I'm just a Jew who doesn't believe in God.
And that maybe was part of my clash with Sam
Harris, because this was during the time of
the new atheists and there was a combative
movement, and I didn't want to be part of
that.
I thought there was a lot to respect about
religion.
So I would do the Shweder thing, which is,
"Okay, you're making these claims about religion.
Well, let's see.
Turn that around, is that really true?"
But back to your question, so no, I don't
incorporate any rituals that are related to
my being an atheist, but I do, yeah, I do
have some rituals.
But this actually almost more comes from Stoic
traditions.
Just that the Stoics advise doing a morning
routine, an evening routine.
Meditations on philosophy in the morning,
and then a taking stock at night.
So I usually try to do that just as an individual
practice to just set my priorities and reflect
on my day and what I'm doing.
And minimally Jewish in the sense of, we go,
my family — my wife is Korean-American,
but she was very happy to have us raise our
kids with some Jewish identity.
My son had a bar mitzvah.
We go to synagogue on the High Holy Days.
We light Shabbat candles and have a family
meal on Friday.
So fairly minimal.
But it is important, I do have a feeling that
something was passed down to the generations
to me, and I don't want to break the chain.
It's a very valuable thing that was passed
down to me and I want my children to have
a sense that they're part of that chain.
Tim Ferriss: Let's talk about from feud to
friends with Sam Harris.
What was, and I know you described it in passing,
but what was the feud?
And then the more interesting part of that
is, I shouldn't say interesting, but the part
that I want to focus on is, how did you go
from that to then friends?
Because that is — feuds are where things
start and end a lot of the time these days,
and maybe forever given human nature, but
certainly online people get rewarded probably
more for feuding than they do for being friendly.
So could you just describe —
Jonathan Haidt: Oh, sure.
Tim Ferriss: — that experience, please?
Jonathan Haidt: Back when Sam really burst
onto the scene, he's a great writer and a
beautiful writer, and he was so persuasive
writing those first two atheist, new atheist
books.
We would be invited to a lot of the same conferences
because I was beginning to write about how
religion — I'm a naturalist, I believe we
evolved to be reli — I don't believe it's
God who made us religious, but religion does
all these good things, I was saying.
So we'd be invited to conferences together.
There was the Beyond Belief Conference.
Sam and all the other new atheists went the
first year, and then Sam and me and one or
two others went the second year.
And wherever I would appear with Sam, or wherever
we would clash in writing, Sam would always
use this rhetorical technique of basically
saying, "So Jon Haidt would say that human
sacrifice among the Aztecs is a good thing
because it binds people..."
So he would always accuse me of supporting
atrocities.
By the third or fourth time he'd done this,
I was, "Okay."
I said before I don't get angry.
I was kind of pissed.
So I did a dirty lowdown trick.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
There must be some decorum.
Yes.
Jonathan Haidt: So I did something, I'm a
little embarrassed by it.
It was clever, but I'm a little embarrassed
now.
I did an academic trick, which is — one
thing that bothered me about Sam.
Sam, he has a PhD, but he wasn't really socialized
as an academic.
He was writing more as a rhetorician, a public
arguer.
He would use very strong language, "always"
this and "never" this and "certainly" this.
So I said, you know what?
Let me take all of Sam's writings and feed
them through this, what's it called?
Oh, shoot.
There's a program that analyzes word use by
Jamie Pennebaker.
Anyway, it's, you feed it through and it counts
"certainly," "always," "never."
So there's a category called certainty.
I fed a text of Sam's books through, and you
get a number, how certain is Sam?
And a couple things like that.
Then I fed in the other new atheists, and
then I fed in all of those, who are all those
Right-wing people?
Rush Limbaugh and Glenn Beck, and I put a
whole bunch of them in.
Then I put in me and David Sloan Wilson, who
is also with me arguing that religion is nuanced
effects.
It turned out that Sam was higher on certainty
words than Glenn Beck and Rush Limbaugh and
all those people.
So I just wrote this up in a blog post, and
I showed graphically that Sam is actually
more certain of himself than these people
that he's always lambasting.
So it was a dirty trick, but it was funny.
Tim Ferriss: And the closing of the first
round ends with a one-two combination.
Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
Oh, and then, I think I offered, I called
it The Moral Psychology Prize or The Sam Harris
Prize or something that — oh, yeah.
Oh, yes.
No, no, okay.
I forgot a crucial thing.
Sam wrote his book, The Moral Landscape, saying
morality is a fact.
And he offered money, I think it was money,
to whoever could persuade him otherwise.
Then I wrote my essay, I bet that no one will
be able to persuade Sam otherwise, and here's
why.
Then I showed that how certain he is.
So I just put him in a bind that if he — anyway,
I can't remember exactly all the details.
Anyway, so that's how it started.
So then we had a little cold — we just ignored
each other for a while.
And my recollection of how it ended was, Sam
is incredibly courageous and is not a partisan
and he thinks for himself, and he does things
that make people hate him on both sides.
I always respected him for that.
It was something, I think it was, he said
something about Islam and he was being lambasted,
and I can't remember whether I retweeted something
or said something.
I put up some little tiny show of support
for him.
I think that's how it went.
And then Sam acknowledged it and thanked me
for it.
What happened was, because our feud was in
2012, 2014, whatever it was.
And that was back before everything went insane.
And around 2014, 2015, everything went insane.
There was this incredible explosion of illiberalism
on campus and in the academic world and the
intellectual world.
Sam and I were then actually both on the same
side, which is we believe in being reasonable
and using evidence.
So we ultimately were natural allies and whatever,
whoever first gave a little show of support
for the other, it was like, "Okay, yeah, you
know what?
I like you."
I've been on his podcast twice and I have
just great admiration for him.
Tim Ferriss: He's a very, very smart cookie.
I'm also a very big fan of Sam.
And flash boil, 2014, 2015, what the hell
happened?
What contributed to things suddenly hockey
sticking in insanity?
Could it have been predicted?
Jonathan Haidt: No.
No, I don't think so.
I find these big ideas that really help me
think, and so I'm going to put another one
out there, which is a complex dynamical system.
Is this something you've talked about on your
show before?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Mm-mm.
Jonathan Haidt: So complex dynamical system.
The human mind is really good at thinking
about mechanical systems, machines, things
moving in space.
We have sort of two brains.
We have sort of two minds.
We have a mind that's really good at thinking
about objects moving in space.
So there's Popular Mechanics for people who
like doing that.
We're really good at thinking about people
moving in social space and forming alliances
and betrayals and soap operas and all that.
So there's People Magazine for people who
like doing that.
Those two things we're really good at, but
there are a lot of things in our world that
are nothing like that.
Like the weather, the economy.
There are complex dynamical systems where
you can't, even in principle, predict what
it's going to do because it's a chaotic complex
system.
You can change parameters and you can kind
of predict which way things are going to go,
but you can't really know.
When you change parameters, you can suddenly
get a phase change.
Mechanical systems are easy to understand.
Complex dynamical systems are very hard, but
we live within them.
So what happened, I believe, is that we hit
a phase change.
It actually began in 2014, but it blew up
in the academic world in 2015.
This is what I've called metaphorically the
fall of the Tower of Babel.
So if you simply wire people up, if you just
connect people more and more, you think that's
good.
We always thought that.
From the Roman roads and the first telegram
cables or the Pony Express, it's good to have
more communication, that's generally a good
thing.
But it could have some problems.
It might be that you just get to a point where
everyone's so connected that everyone is yelling
or everyone's mad at everyone.
So it might just be that there's more and
more connection, but I think it's something
else.
What I've come to believe in trying to understand
what the hell happened is it's the nature
of the connection changed after 2009.
Once, we used to call social network sites,
they connected people, so you could use Facebook
to communicate with your friends from high
school.
That was great.
There's no problem there.
But in 2009, Facebook introduced the like
button.
Twitter introduced the retweet button, Facebook
copied it with the share button.
So social media isn't just connecting people
anymore.
We stopped talking about them as social networking
sites.
We start using the word social media platform.
Now it becomes about performance and it becomes
much more viral, much more explosive.
It's not about me talking with you, it's about
me talking at you in the hopes that my slam
on you will get picked up by others, and that
will make me famous.
That will get me prestige.
Once everyone's motivated to do that, or I
should say once 10 percent of people are motivated
to do that, the system develops new properties
that were not there in 2008.
Most of us, most of your listeners, if they're
old enough, can remember it used to be an
amazing place.
The internet was amazing.
Social media was amazing.
Twitter was playful and fun.
It's still that in part, but it just became
much nastier.
One of the key innovations, I believe, was
what Facebook called threaded comments.
So it used to be if Barack Obama puts up a
Tweet in his first term, he puts it up and
people can respond and that's it.
They just respond and that's it.
You can say, "You're stupid," or, "You're
terrible," and that's it.
You say that.
But in 2014, Facebook said, "How about, to
increase engagement, how about we let everyone
fight with everyone everywhere?"
So if Barack Obama puts up a Facebook post
in his second term, or after 2014, someone
can say, "Go back to Kenya."
And then someone else can say to that commenter,
"No, you are a fascist."
And then before you know it, you've got people
fighting in the comments.
So it's like those scenes in a barroom brawl,
you've got two people having a face off and
suddenly everyone's breaking bottles in everyone's
heads.
That, I believe, is what happened in 2014,
2015.
Democracy is unsustainable, institutions are
collapsing, universities are going crazy.
So we're now in the post Babel world where
we can't have any shared understandings of
truth.
We can't have any shared stories.
Hence the title of my forthcoming book, Life
after Babel: Adapting to a World We Can No
Longer Share.
Tim Ferriss: Do you have thoughts on what
we can do from a proactive incentive perspective
to, I don't want to say reverse some of these
trends, but to redirect the currents slightly
in different directions?
And you mentioned Chicago.
One thing that really jumped out to me, this
is quite a few years ago now I want to say,
but when the woke supremacy virus started
spreading throughout academia and fragility
was being reinforced and tripled down upon,
I want to say it was the University of Chicago,
put out a letter to say —
Jonathan Haidt: Oh, yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Tim Ferriss: — "We are actually going to
go in the opposite direction."
It was notable to me because a number of friends
of mine who are alumni from U of Chicago said,
"This is the first time in 10 years that I've
given money to the university."
So there are, I guess, a number of questions
in this word salad that I'm throwing at you.
The first is, why do you think U of Chicago
was able to do that then, or willing to do
it?
And would they be willing to do it again now?
Just to understand the incentives, because
I've seen so many people lose their posts,
doesn't seem to matter how high up you are,
if you can be removed by the trustees, you
are vulnerable, or whatever mechanism exists
for replacing the top brass.
Then separately, let's focus on the academic
side first, and then we can look at the technological
side and maybe the business side.
So in the academic world, why do you think
it was possible for U of Chicago to do it
then?
Could they do it now?
And is it possible to create some type of
counterbalance or change incentives such that
this doesn't continue to go in the direction
it's going?
Jonathan Haidt: Yes.
I can't answer that question until I explain
the dynamics that have made leaders cave throughout
the intellectual world, throughout the, let's
call it, we have democratic institutions and
we have epistemic institutions.
Epistemic meaning in search of knowledge.
So that's preeminently the universities in
journalism, museums, other things like that.
Why have they all fallen in the same way?
Let me start with that and then we'll get
to Chicago.
I've been trying to figure this out every
day.
I've been obsessed with this since it started
in 2014.
That's when Greg Lukianoff came to me.
Greg is the President of The Foundation for
Individual Rights in Education.
He said, "Jon, weird stuff is happening on
campus.
Students are suddenly asking for protections
from books, word speakers, ideas."
Before then it was always administrators.
So Greg says, "What's going on?
The students seem to be explaining these things
using the same cognitive distortions that
I learned to not do when I was treated for
depression."
Greg suffers from depression and he learned
cognitive behavioral therapy.
Anyway, so I thought Greg's idea was brilliant.
Somehow universities are teaching students
to think, to catastrophize, overgeneralize,
mind reading, all these distortions.
So that starts in 2014 and then it's really
the fall of 2015, especially after the Halloween
incident at Yale where the students demand
that Nicholas Christakis apologize for a thoughtful,
caring letter that his wife had written to
the students of Silliman College.
Then the President of Yale, Peter Salovey
never backed up the Christakises.
They demanded that they be fired, and the
president just gave the students everything
they demanded that he could.
He couldn't give them everything, but he really
made a big show of saying, "Yes, I will.
You're right."
And that launched a wave of protests around
the country.
It always goes the same way, which is a charge
from a student that something that was said
was insensitive about race, gender, LGBTQ,
and then there's never a finding of information.
It blows up on Twitter or other channels,
and then within a day or two, the person's
fired, no due process.
This keeps going.
It happened at The New York Times, it just
happened at the Association for Psychological
Science here.
An editor may have made a mistake.
It looks like he probably didn't follow good
process.
But again, there's a mob and then the leadership
gives in.
So that's what's been happening.
Tim Ferriss: Why are they all caving?
I'm just trying to think of the incentives,
because it doesn't happen everywhere.
Right?
Jonathan Haidt: Right.
Tim Ferriss: There are some counterexamples.
Yeah.
Jonathan Haidt: It happens when you get moral
homogeneity.
So you get an institution where the great
majority, or almost everybody's on one side.
In epistemic institutions, it's always going
to be the Left.
Now you can have a craziness on an all Right-wing
institution, but there aren't any institutions
on the Right that are as high, that have so
little diversity as those on the Left.
On the Left, it's often the case that there's
not a single person on the Right.
I rarely encounter a Conservative in the academic
world, they're very, very few.
Whereas when I've spoken at military installations,
or if you have a Right-leaning thing, there's
still going to be some Liberals there.
Anyway, so you have moral homogeneity, which
is a crucial background variable.
In moral homogeneity, you have students, so
usually it's members of Gen — oh, you have
Gen Z.
So the charges are usually from Gen Z or late
Millennials making a charge that the leadership
is vulnerable to, because the leadership is
usually older white Liberals, and it's backed
up with a barrage of darts.
A dart is anything that someone can do to
hurt someone else.
You can launch a dart on Twitter, you can
make an accusation, you have no liability
for it.
So what you see is these leaders, suddenly
they're in morally homogeneous, politically
homogeneous institutions.
They're attacked with darts, they cave instantly.
It's very painful.
They cave instantly, that just encourages
the darters to go further.
So I called this in a recent Atlantic article,
I called this structural stupidity.
That is, you can have very smart people, but
you only get smart when bad ideas will be
challenged, and if a bad idea — so for example,
at universities, we all now have bias response
teams.
So if I say anything and a student objects,
they can report me in three ways.
That number is posted in the bathrooms, it's
on the back of all the ID cards, like, "Here's
911.
Here's campus safety.
Here's the bias response line.
If you're offended, call this number."
This is a really, really bad idea.
Or at least, there's no evidence that it's
a good idea.
But it's done everywhere.
It's done everywhere, because no one dares
oppose it.
Nobody in the faculty senate will say, "Well,
wait a second, do we really want to do this?"
Everyone's just like, "Oh, yeah, let's do
this.
This will be anti-racist."
So you get structurally stupid communities
and they all fold in exactly the same way.
This is what happened at The New York Times
with the firing of James Bennet.
It's the same thing everywhere.
Why was Chicago different?
Two reasons.
So every institution has its own moral resources.
Every institution has a sense of identity.
Chicago is unique in having this really intense
intellectual, really high intellectual identity.
When I was there, students wore t-shirts,
"University of Chicago: where fun goes to
die."
They were ranked, Playboy Magazine ranked
them the least, the worst party school in
America, 300th out of 300, don't go to Chicago.
And they were proud of it.
So they begin with this intellectually intense
identity, the background, and then the other
crucial element was leadership.
They had Robert Zimmer, that's it.
Robert Zimmer personally was calling bullshit
on all this stuff.
Like, "This is not who we are.
This, the caving, the demands, the outrage
mobs, no, we're going to talk about ideas
here."
Robert Zimmer single-handedly said, "No."
And that letter that you referred to was not
from him.
It was by a dean of students who sent a letter
to prospective students who are coming to
Chicago.
He said, "At Chicago, we don't do safe space."
Now he misspoke, that was a mistake, because
if the gay students or LGBT students want
to have a club where they have certain discourse
rules, great, free association, let them.
What the dean meant to say was, "Our classrooms
are not safe spaces.
In our classrooms people can criticize what
you say."
If you have that, then you don't have structural
stupidity.
Tim Ferriss: So if we're looking at structural
stupidity, I start to think about structural
dynamics and the ways in which people are
vulnerable or less vulnerable to losing their
posts.
Let's just say, you are Brian Armstrong, CEO
of Coinbase, and the company is doing well
and you want to remove, and I don't want to
speak for him, but this has been very well
covered.
You want to put out a letter that effectively
says, "This is our mission.
If you're aligned with this mission, great.
But we cannot be responsible for every cause
or world event that pulls our direction at
a given velocity towards whatever outcome
you might want.
Therefore, if you would like to discuss these
things and feel like it should be done at
work —
Jonathan Haidt: Go elsewhere.
Tim Ferriss: — we're going to give you a
fantastic severance package."
Part of the reason he can do that, aside from,
I think, being very courageous, thinking for
himself, and being willing to take a lot of
flak in the short term, in the long-term best
interest of the company, putting that aside,
he's also, I think, in doing that, unlikely
to get fired.
It would take the board of directors to remove
him and then there's the question of, "Well,
who would we replace him with who would actually
be a good enough operator to do a better job?
Going to be very tough."
I suppose what I'm wondering is, within academics,
do you think there's anything that can be
done to provide protections or safety nets
such that more people can actually take a
counterposition?
Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
Yes.
Let's start by understanding the complex dynamical
system of a company in a capitalist economy.
All of the stuff that started on campus in
2015, Greg and I wrote about it in The Coddling
of the American Mind.
We were going to have a chapter on the coddling
goes to work, but there weren't enough stories
in 2017 when we were finishing the writing,
so we closed down the book.
Then in 2018 it all starts blowing up, all
this stuff because Gen Z graduates, they move
into the corporate world and they do the same
stuff there that they were doing on campus.
The accusations that, "Someone wore a hat
that offended me.
You have to punish them.
This is an HR issue."
So all that stuff starts around 2018 and 2019.
Then, of course, in the summer of George Floyd,
the political activism intensifies for, again,
understandable reasons, but in that summer,
almost all businesses, it seems, put out a
statement on Black Lives Matter.
Now, that was an exceptional summer, exceptional
event, but that then led to pressures that
then led to a reorientation of much of corporate
America, at least in Progressively oriented,
Progressive-leaning companies, much like what
happened to us in the academy in 2015, 2016.
It was very, very similar.
But the difference is that companies actually
have to make money.
They actually have to be tied to the real
world.
So if they do things that backfire, that cost
a lot of money without any benefit, like mandatory
diversity training, it takes a lot of money.
There's not really any evidence that makes
anything better.
At some point, reality hits companies, whereas
universities are different.
They're not like that.
There is no reality.
The leading ones have gigantic, well, they
have gigantic endowments.
No matter how bad the service is, parents
all over the world want their kids to go to
the top 10 or 15 American universities.
It doesn't matter what happens, the product
can suck, but the demand for it is infinite.
So universities are not tied to reality in
the way that a business is.
That's the first thing.
Second thing is that most businesses are not
as uniform as universities.
Of course, Armstrong, I presume he's Right
of Center or Libertarian.
Do you know?
Tim Ferriss: I don't want to speak for him.
I'm not sure.
Jonathan Haidt: Is he Conservative?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I honestly have no idea.
Jonathan Haidt: Okay.
But in any — yeah.
But I don't think he's Progressive.
I think he was — so my point is that a number
of Right-leaning CEOs did that, and he was
the first big one.
And it's called the mission focus movement.
That, "You know what?
Our company is not here to fix everything
in the world.
We're here to provide a great service for
our customers."
So mission-focused.
And a few right-leaning companies did that.
And the one that really changed things then
was when Netflix did it.
Because Netflix is a very Progressive company,
hugely important culturally.
And when the Netflix CEO said something similar,
which was, "If your values mean that you can't
work on certain projects, maybe you shouldn't
be working at Netflix."
And I speak to a lot of managers and CEOs
and leaders and like, "Ugh."
They were so thrilled because almost all leaders
hate this woke stuff.
Almost all university presidents hate it.
Makes their lives hell.
So in the business world, they're able to
push back, and they have been.
So the pendulum is swinging back in business.
I don't yet see a sign on campus of a pendulum
swinging back.
I think it will happen eventually.
The complex dynamical system is much more
conducive to a kind of crazy ideological thing
divorced from reality on campus.
But the way it's going to break, I believe,
is things get sort of tense enough, unpleasant
enough, wasteful enough, and then some school
is going to break.
And I originally thought Chicago was the school,
and lots of schools would follow.
And they didn't.
Nobody followed Chicago.
I mean, Mitch Daniels at Purdue, but that's
a different story.
He's a Conservative.
So I'm on the advisory board of the University
of Austin.
Austin, the new — are you involved with
it at all?
It's in your hometown there.
Tim Ferriss: I'm not involved, but I have
some passing familiarity.
For people who don't have any familiarity,
can you just explain what it is?
Jonathan Haidt: Mm-hmm.
Yeah, so it's a university founded on the
idea of we're going to rethink what a university
should be.
And Pano Kanelos is the president.
He was the president of St. John's College
in Maryland.
And so it's going to be focused on — it's
not going to have all the administrators,
all the bells and whistles.
It's going to really be focused on sort of
a classics education at the beginning, but
then practical as you move on.
So a lot of not just take a course, get a
credit for sitting in a seat, but do things
as part of a team to solve a problem.
So it's going to be given that higher ed now
is so expensive and is not as good as it used
to be.
The product is just not as good.
It's not as much fun.
It's not as rigorous.
So given that the product is declining while
the price goes up, Austin is developing a
model where the price is much, much lower.
The product is a hell of a lot of fun.
It's very exciting, and now it's just one
university.
But the idea is it's going to be a model for
a lot of other universities to either change
or be founded because I think we do need disruption
and innovation.
We need alternatives.
We can't just have the one sort of Ivy League
model of top universities, and they're all
making the same mistakes at the same time.
Tim Ferriss: I have a number of questions
that float to the surface, and I apologize
for what is going to be a very inelegant way
of posing them.
But I'm going to give you a menu of options,
and I'd love for you to choose whichever is
of the greatest interest.
So something that came to mind was how you
have preserved your ability or ensured your
ability to speak very openly about these things
by maybe diversifying your identity and professional
career.
So not just teaching, but also books and so
on.
Speaking, I assume.
So you have a number of backup parachutes,
I would say.
Perhaps in a sense.
So maybe that's something to talk about.
But what I wanted to ask you, specifically
related to University of Austin, because I
did do a bit of reading related to it in prep
for the Niall Ferguson conversation.
Jonathan Haidt: Mm-hmm.
Tim Ferriss: It seems like, and I don't know
if this coverage is accurate, but that some
people have start to finish strong supporters.
There are and have been a number of very notable
names involved.
So I encourage people to check it out.
It seems like there have also been people
who agreed to be on advisory boards and so
on who have folded or broken rank with public
criticism.
How would you describe the reception and some
of those dynamics if what I'm reading is accurate?
Jonathan Haidt: Mm-hmm.
Well, we're in a space that is heavily politicized.
There's a lot of attacks, almost all on Twitter
and social media.
Most professors are reasonable.
Most professors are Left, Center Left.
They believe in free speech.
They believe in that class we should talk
about ideas.
So wherever you go, most people are reasonable.
But the dynamics are such that if you stick
your neck out, this small fringe of academic
Twitter is going to call you racist, sexist,
transphobe, whatever.
And for a while, that was really scary.
And I think now it's kind of like "The Boy
Who Cried Wolf" 10 million times once everyone's
accused of racism, sexism, transphobia, Islamophobia.
I think now people are just so exhausted that
I think now it's a little easier to stand
that, that fringe on Twitter.
When the University of Austin was announced,
I think there was a mistake in that some of
the original material was a little bit pugnacious,
and it sounded sort of like, "This is going
to be an anti-woke university."
And once any particle is labeled like anti-woke,
now suddenly it's like, "Oh, now it's..."
So I think there was a little brouhaha.
I think that was a one fumble that the people
running it made in what was otherwise, I think,
a very good launch.
I mean, I think they really explained well
what it's going to be about.
So I wish they hadn't done that because the
point — well, what I've learned from studying
morality is, in a polarization spiral or a
culture war, the harder you hit your enemy,
the stronger they get.
And so you don't win by punching them really
hard.
You can never destroy them.
In a real war, you can literally kill them
and take their land.
But in a culture war, you can't do that.
And so I think it's really important.
This is what we've done at Heterodox Academy.
So I founded an organization called Heterodox
Academy.
It's now run by John Tomasi as our president.
And our attitude is we're not here to fight
the culture war.
We're here to build great things.
We're here to help people remember why they
love universities.
Why universities are so important.
And I think Austin is doing that.
So I think, early on, it was a new thing,
and it wasn't clear what it was.
And there were one or two people who left
the advisory board at that early stage.
But I think now it's settled in.
It's being successful.
It doesn't yet have a full year of — had
a summer program.
And I think we need variation.
We need innovation.
And so I'm actually very excited about it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I agree.
I'm excited to watch it.
Could you say a bit more about Heterodox Academy?
Jonathan Haidt: Oh, I'd love to.
So I gave a talk in 2011.
I was invited by the president of the Society
for Personality and Social Psychology to be
part of a panel at our annual conference on
the future of social psychology.
And we talked about my stepping out in 1993.
I'm not on a team.
I was still very much a Democrat.
I voted for Democrats.
By the time I was writing The Righteous Mind,
I began to really take seriously that you
need viewpoint diversity.
You need Conservatives and Libertarians.
You can't just have a bunch of Progressives
studying psychology.
You get bad results.
And so I gave a talk on how this is a problem.
This is a problem.
We don't have any Conservatives.
And I went through all kinds of methods of
finding a Conservative social psychologist.
I couldn't find any.
And I finally found one.
So I gave a talk on this, and I wasn't kicked
out of the field.
People actually said, "Oh, you're right.
Actually, this would help us if we had some
political diversity."
So that was 2011.
And this was just a problem about the faculty,
and some other professors who were there liked
what I said.
They said, "Yeah, we think this is a problem
too."
So we wrote a paper together on laying it
out more formally, and I think the title was
"Political Diversity Will Improve Social Psychological
Science."
So this is a straight academic faculty project.
And then it turns out, actually, the same
problem was happening in law schools and sociology.
In a lot of fields, their research was not
reliable because of orthodoxy, political orthodoxy.
So we all got together and said, "Hey, let's
put up a website."
And Nick Rosenkrantz, a law professor at Georgetown,
came up with the name Heterodox Academy.
It's the opposite of Orthodox Academy.
Orthodox means straight, one — there's only
one way of thinking.
Heterodox means there should be a variety
of ways of thinking.
We need that in order to be successful.
So we put up the website.
We started it as a blog around September 12th
of 2015.
And very soon, right after that, Yale blew
up, the universities blew up, and suddenly
it was like, "Wait a second.
We thought this was just a faculty thing.
But now it turns out the campuses are going
insane.
The students are behaving in this strange
way.
They're saying everything is violence, everything
is danger, everything's a threat."
So Heterodox Academy grew from just this faculty
project to really being much more about university
culture.
To do our jobs, we have to have not just viewpoint
diversity but a sense of grace, a sense of
tolerance, a sense of intellectual humility,
and generosity.
We have to be able to think together.
We have to have people like Rick Shweder saying,
"Okay, you asserted that.
Well, let me try the opposite."
And then they don't get fired for doing it.
So that's what we're trying to do.
Heterodox Academy now has — we have a couple
of big projects.
One is we're branching out and having campus
communities where we're going to be working
directly on campus with our many — we have
about 5,000 members.
And I invite everyone who's listening here,
if you are a professor or an administrator,
if you're an insider to universities, if you're
part of the community that is tasked with
preserving these precious institutions, please
go to heterodoxacademy.org and click on "About
Us" and join.
You can see our membership.
It's free.
We have 5,000 professors as members, and we're
equally divided, Left, Right, Libertarian.
We're sort of all over the map.
And it's a wonderful community.
If you remember when it was fun, when there
were jokes and exciting ideas, if you remember
when everything wasn't so dangerous, please
join us because that's what we're trying to
recall and restore.
Tim Ferriss: Who are some of the thinkers
who have informed how you think about intellectual
heterodoxy?
And I will throw one out there because I think
that —
Jonathan Haidt: Okay.
Tim Ferriss: — John Stuart Mill.
Jonathan Haidt: Oh, yes.
Tim Ferriss: And is this quote from John Stuart
Mill, "He who knows his own side of the case,
knows little of that."
Is that John Stuart —
Jonathan Haidt: "He who knows only his own
side…"
Tim Ferriss: Only.
Jonathan Haidt: "...of the case — only his
own side of the case knows little of that."
Exactly.
That's right.
So John Stuart Mill is the patron saint of
viewpoint diversity.
In fact, I would urge — I should have a
copy of it here somewhere.
One of the greatest works of the Liberal tradition
is On Liberty.
It's a kind of a long book with dense prose.
But chapter two is the key chapter on diversity
of thought or freedom of thought.
Liberty of thought, I think it is.
So at Heterodox Academy, we took that chapter.
It's 15,000 words.
We cut it in half.
We edit it down.
So you have a shortened version, much easier
to read.
And it's beautifully illustrated by brilliant
artist Dave Cicirelli.
So if you go to heterodoxacademy.org/mil.
It's a free ebook.
You can buy it on Amazon for $20.
But we put out a free ebook because we want
students to read it.
And I mean, it really just makes the case
that you need viewpoint diversity.
If you want to get smart, if you want to figure
things out, an amazing thing happens.
And this is what I've really taken to heart
from studying John Stuart Mill, is if you
want to improve your thought, the world will
help you if you ask.
And if you go to people who disagree with
you and say, "Here's what I'm thinking, where
am I wrong?"
They'll tell you.
And so when Greg and I wrote The Coddling
of the American Mind, I paid seven social
justice activists to read it.
Paid them each $700, and they read it and
they gave me their comments and their criticisms,
but one or two of them were kind of pissed
off or annoyed.
But the others were actually like, "Oh, this
is interesting.
We really engaged with each other."
And they made the book better.
So you really need to seek out criticism.
You need to seek out people who differ from
you, and then, actually, you'll get smarter.
Tim Ferriss: Have you found other people who
have studied morality to defuse or defang
their anger in the same way that you experienced
it yourself?
Is that a pattern that you've observed in
other people?
Jonathan Haidt: What?
The ability to defang the anger to get past
it?
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Well, your description of how you, I wouldn't
say ceased to be angry, but lost your anger
in the course of studying morality.
Is that something that you have seen replicated
in other people or is that —
Jonathan Haidt: Oh, yes.
Oh, yes.
So, first of all, the Buddhists and the Stoics.
These are the two most concentrated wisdom
traditions on earth, I believe.
My first book, The Happiness Hypothesis, was
about — I read all the ancient wisdom I
could find, took out all the psychological
claims.
And so chapter four of that book is on the
ancient idea of, "Why do you see the speck
in your neighbor's eye when you cannot see
the plank in your own?"
We're all hypocrites.
So following certain wisdom traditions, especially
Buddhism and Stoicism, but also Christianity,
Judaism, you find these injunctions to go
past good and evil to be more tolerant.
So this is just sort of the progression of
wisdom that most great cultures have realized.
You also see it in a lot of people.
I think as people get older — so at least
in men, our testosterone levels, they're really
high in the teens, 20s, and then they sort
of go down steadily.
And that steady drop, I think, it also mirrors
the drop in violent criminality.
And I believe it also mirrors the drop in
aggressive rock music.
I used to always need loud music, and as I
get older, I don't.
But I think it's just — also, it's calming.
So young men are more passionate and moralistic,
perhaps.
And then, as you get older, you get kind of
calmer.
But there are lots of paragons of this.
Daryl Davis being, perhaps, one of the preeminent
ones.
Daryl Davis, a Black musician, blues musician,
who was playing in a bar and ended up sitting
next to a Ku Klux Klan member, and he's conversing
with the guy.
And rather than getting upset or angry or
running away, he listens to him and listens
to him, gets in a conversation with him, and
they develop a friendship.
And he gets the guy to give up his robe and
leave the Klan.
And he's done this hundreds of times.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
How do you spell Daryl's name?
Jonathan Haidt: Daryl Davis.
Yeah.
D-A-R-Y-L or is it double R?
Daryl Davis is D-A-V-I-S.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Jonathan Haidt: He's got a one or two TED
Talks that are great, and he's got a book
or two.
So Daryl Davis, what an inspiring example
of how is your goal to impress everyone else
with your righteous reaction.
Well, if so, then you should get angry, and
you should yell and scream, and you should
post things on Twitter.
Or is your goal to actually change someone?
And if your goal is to change someone, listen
to them, try to understand them.
And if you do that, what Daryl says is, "You
listen to them like they've never been listened
to before.
And then an amazing thing happens.
Then they'll listen to you."
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Jonathan Haidt: And so that's really the magic.
And this is also Dale Carnegie.
This is so many wise people that the things
we do to show off our morality for others
end up isolating us and making us stupid.
Tim Ferriss: And unhappy, oftentimes, it would
seem.
Jonathan Haidt: Unhappy.
Yeah.
Well, anger, shared anger, actually.
So, anger in the brain is actually an approach.
Anger is not a negative emotion.
Anger in the brain, it looks more like a positive
emotion because a shared anger is thrilling,
and that's part of what's driving us off a
cliff as a country.
Tim Ferriss: What would you say are some of
the conclusions or observations made in The
Happiness Hypothesis that you revisit most
often or underscore for yourself?
And what is your set point, if you have one?
Jonathan Haidt: Let's see, what's my set point?
Yeah.
So the set point question is easy.
That just refers to the fact that happiness
is heritable.
And identical twins separated at birth will
tend to be similarly happy.
And my set point's sort of right in the middle.
I'm not born — I'm generally optimistic,
but I've been depressed at a couple of points
in my life.
I'm not very prone to it, but I've had some.
And so I'm sort of in the middle.
But the level of happiness that you live at
is not your set point.
Where you live is sort of a range around your
set point, depending on a few conditions.
And those conditions are basically love and
work, as Sigmund Freud said.
Love and work.
Those are — if you're doing well in those,
you'll be at the top end of your range.
So I teach a course at NYU, a graduate seminar
called "Work, Wisdom, and Happiness."
And it's a positive psychology class.
But in the last year, I've sort of readjusted
the syllabus.
I've rewired the course so that the title
could be "Smarter, Stronger, More Sociable."
And so we have sections on how do you get
smarter.
And you do that — it turns out the big thing
you do, turn off your notifications, get your
attention back.
Read Johann Hari's book Stolen Focus.
So you can make yourself 10 or 15 IQ points
smarter if you can regain control of your
attention and cut down on the moralism.
Those are the two big steps.
So how do you get smarter?
How do you get stronger?
That's The Coddling of the American Mind,
Antifragility, Nassim Taleb.
You get stronger by challenging yourself,
by exposing yourself to threats and dangers
within limits that you then surmount, and
we have to do this with kids.
And how do you get more sociable?
Well, it's actually some of the same skills,
but the main one is really listen to people.
And you can't do that as long as you're always
distracted, as long as you're always on your
phone.
So there are some really easy things you can
do.
And then the students learn to do some harder
things.
But if they can get smarter, stronger, and
more sociable, then they will be more successful
at work and in relationships.
And if they're more successful in work and
relationships, then I promise them on the
first day, then they will be happier because
that's how you live at the high end of your
set range is by having your love and your
work go well.
Tim Ferriss: Is this course in any capacity
available online or could it be made available
online?
Any aspect?
Maybe a reading list?
Maybe questions?
Jonathan Haidt: Well, the syllabus is online.
And you know what, I should do something like
— so right now — so it was just a seminar
at Stern with 35 MBA students, twice — two
sections a year.
And I've just raised it to 55 students while
teaching more sections.
I should put something up.
You know what?
I'm going to start a Substack.
Oh, my God, this is great.
I'm actually going to start a Substack in
January.
I can't believe I have — I didn't even think
of this.
The Substack people would kill me for not
announcing this.
Yeah.
So it's going to be called After Babbel is
the name of the Substack, and I can just put
up whatever I want.
I used to blog at righteousmind.com, but that
was not much.
So I'm going to start blogging, and I thank
you for that, Tim.
I will put some — whatever I can put easily
online or in there.
I will put there, at least, the reading list
and the syllabus.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing.
Jonathan Haidt: And eventually, maybe, I could
make — I could tape the lectures or do something
to put — yeah, I'll think about it.
Tim Ferriss: Is there a department and number
for the class?
Something that people could look for online?
I'm not sure how that would work in MBA programs,
but I'm just thinking.
The class that I used to visit at Princeton
was ELE 491, right?
High-tech entrepreneurship.
Jonathan Haidt: Right.
Tim Ferriss: So it made it easy to find.
Jonathan Haidt: Oh, yeah.
There's no point in them finding it because
it's —
Tim Ferriss: There's nothing.
Jonathan Haidt: — it fills up with Stern
students.
Even if you're at NYU but not at Stern, you
can't take it.
But I will.
But if you just go to — so all my stuff
is at jonathanhaidt.com.
I will find a way to put it on my site, and
then I will — I think our discussion, it
might air before New Year's, but the Substack
isn't going to be up until late January, probably.
But just I'll do something.
Thank you.
Tim Ferriss: And it's easy for us to put in
the show notes, so once anything is available
—
Jonathan Haidt: Oh, yeah, okay.
Tim Ferriss: — we can add it to the show
notes at tim.blog/podcast, and people can
find you by just searching H-A-I-D-T.
Let's talk about religion and happiness.
So I have observed, I'm not the only one.
Generally speaking, I would say the, let's
just say, self-described, rational, materialist,
Left-leaning folks to be pretty unhappy.
That is a — overall.
Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: And I have found very smart,
very thoughtful people who would identify
as religious to on average be quite a bit
happier.
And I know happy can be a slippery term, but
if we're looking at work and love, work and
relationships, they seem to check a lot of
boxes very well.
But it seems to me, and I'm just going to
speak for a second here, that with religion,
you also remove a lot of uncertainty, decision
fatigue, paradox of choice that makes life
less of a death by a thousand paper cuts.
And maybe that also contributes to general
sense of well-being, that many of your decisions
are more automated, perhaps people you spend
time with, perhaps your weekly structure,
the architecture of your life.
How do you think about this?
What have you seen in your observations and
studies with respect to religion and happiness?
And are there ingredients from religion —
Jonathan Haidt: Yes.
Tim Ferriss: — that secular folks can borrow
to get some of that upside?
Jonathan Haidt: Yes.
So there's a huge amount of research on happiness
and who's happy.
And the two big things that really come out
consistently are religious people are happier
and married people are happier.
Religion and marriage are the two giant demographic
factors or quasi-demographic factors that
seem to go with happiness.
And then there's a lot of question as to why.
Why does religion make people happier?
It might be what you said.
You don't have to think about things.
You have a sense of meaning.
You don't worry about the afterlife, whatever
it is.
No, it turns out when they look, you do empirical
studies of what elements of religious people's
lives correlate with happiness.
Overwhelmingly, it's nothing about belief.
It's participation in a community on a weekly
basis, especially a community that has some
sort of moral principle, some sense of uplifting,
some sense of self-control, binding moral
responsibility.
And so, actually, this allows me to go back
to Durkheim.
I dropped that name in before but didn't really
tell listeners anything about him.
So Émile Durkheim is one of the most important
sociologists in history.
He's writing in France in the 1890s and early
1900s.
And one of his early works is this incredible
study of suicide.
Now, this is when European countries are just
beginning to collect statistics.
And he goes through all the data he can get
on suicide in different countries in Europe.
And he is looking for what makes the suicide
rate go up and down.
And he treats the suicide rate as a thing
in itself.
It's a sociological fact.
It's an emergent fact about a country.
Its rate goes up and down.
What makes it go up and down?
Well, when you go to war, the suicide rate
goes way down.
People are bound together.
They don't kill themselves.
When you look at who in a country kills themselves,
it turns out if you're married, you're less
likely to.
If you're married with children, you're even
less likely to.
Whereas if you're Protestant, you're more
likely to, but if you're Catholic or Jewish,
you're less likely to.
And over and over, what he finds is the degree
to which people are bound into a society,
the less likely they are to kill themselves.
Now, in East Asian cultures, in many cultures,
you kill yourself because you're too tightly
bound and you're ashamed.
But in Western cultures, our problem is anomie
or normlessness.
You have a sense of meaninglessness.
You're not connected.
That's why Americans and Westerners kill themselves
mostly.
And so, back to religion.
If you are an atheist and you're not part
of a community, and especially if you're a
new atheist and you're angry or whatever.
But the protective factor seems to be being
bound into relationships and community.
And that fits with everything else I know
in psychology.
Tim Ferriss: The comment on wartime also makes
me think about Tribe by Sebastian Junger,
which I —
Jonathan Haidt: Oh, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: — highly recommend to people.
It really underscores the fragility of isolation
and also the fragility of fetishizing comfort
in a way.
I suggest people take a look at that.
Well, Jonathan, we've covered a lot here,
and I could ask many more questions, but what
have I neglected to ask?
And I do have a question about heresies of
yours in a moment, but is there anything that
you would like to bring up that I have not
mentioned?
Jonathan Haidt: Yes.
So haven't talked about what's happening to
Gen Z.
We haven't talked about what's happening to
kids.
I talked about them before in a sort of negative
way, like Gen Z shows up on campus, and then
all of a sudden, there are all these problems.
But again, I don't get angry.
I'm not moralistic.
We have to understand what's happening to
Gen Z.
So I just want to talk, if I can, just talk
a little bit about that.
Tim Ferriss: Please.
And could also define Gen Z?
And then please continue.
Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
So Millennials are those who were born in
1982, and we used to think that it would go
to maybe 2000.
But it turns out that kids who were born in
1996 and later are different from those born,
say, 1994 and earlier.
I mean, it's a surprisingly sharp-cut equivalent
to what we find with birth here in 1946.
The post-war world really was different to
grow up in.
And I believe — so I'm drawing on work by
Jean Twenge, but I've also added — she and
I are working together, and I've added a lot.
What happened is that if you were born in,
say, 1990, you didn't get an iPhone until
maybe around 2009, '10 is when teenagers started
getting it.
So if you're born in 1990, you didn't get
an iPhone, a smartphone until you were 20.
And you didn't get on social media.
You might've been on Facebook partly, but
you don't live on social media until you have
your own smartphone.
Whereas if you're born in 1997, you are 13
in 2010 when you might get your first smartphone,
and you might get on Instagram in 2012 when
huge numbers did.
So I believe Gen Z is defined by the fact
that they got smartphones and social media
during early puberty.
There's a lot of research pointing to early
puberty, around 11 to 13 for girls, 12 to
15 for boys.
What's coming into your brain then is really
important because your frontal cortex is wiring
itself up.
And so when human beings are raised without
much independence, but yes, with a phone,
and they spend their childhood just interacting
with a screen, and especially social media,
I believe it messes up cortical development.
The girls, in particular, the rates of anxiety
and depression are up much more than 100 percent
since 2010.
The rate of self-harm, hospitalization for
self-harm is nearly tripled for preteen girls.
So Gen Z is in big, big trouble.
They're hurting.
They're fragile.
They're not doing well in the workplace.
Managers are finding them very hard to work
with.
So we have a generation that's running off
the rails, and this is not a moralistic thing
like, "Oh, those kids these days."
This is a compassionate thing.
These are our children.
My kids are 13 and 16.
Everyone either has kids or that has nieces
and nephews.
So this is, I think, the greatest emergency
we face.
The greatest health emergency.
I think for kids, this is much, much bigger
than COVID.
COVID was a big deal for old people.
It wasn't a big deal for children in terms
of the risk, but this is a doubling, more
than doubling of suicide rates for kids since
2010.
So that's what I'm working on now.
Tim Ferriss: What decisions have you made
in your parenting that you feel have been
perhaps most impactful, less typical, or the
Venn diagram of those two overlapping?
Jonathan Haidt: The terrible mental health
of Gen Z is caused by two factors.
One is the vast overprotection.
Kids need to practice independence, self-governance
from the time they're seven or eight.
They need independence, but they don't get
it anymore.
You and I, when we were growing up — you're
younger than me, but I presume you were allowed
to roam around your neighborhood when you
were eight years old.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I was free range.
Yeah.
Riding bikes everywhere when I was younger.
I was also in a rural environment.
But yeah, I was out and about very early.
Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
So kids must have free-range childhoods.
They must practice independence.
And they had that before the '90s.
And in the '90s, things got incredibly safe.
We locked up the drunk drivers.
We took the perverts off the street, crime
plummets, but we freaked out about child induction
unnecessarily.
So in the '90s, we stopped letting kids out,
and this affects Gen Z and the late Millennials.
Anyway, but you asked about me.
So what my wife and I did, we live here in
New York City, in Greenwich Village, because
we're friends with Lenore Skenazy, who wrote
this fantastic book, Free-Range Kids.
We let our kids out to play in Washington
Square Park.
We sent them out on errands when they were
eight, nine years old.
New York City was very safe back then.
It's a little more dangerous now, but it was
very, very safe in the mid — in the 2010s.
And we sent them out, and we had them walk
to school way — a year or two before anyone
else was doing it.
So I'm very glad we did that.
We also made it clear no social media, at
least until high school, absolutely none in
middle school.
And that's been very good.
When they start sixth grade, my kids tell
me everyone's on Instagram, and we said, "No,
we are not going to let you do it."
The one mistake I made was that when my son
wanted Fortnite in sixth grade, and we said
no because video games can be addictive.
But now that I've dug into the literature
a lot more, now I see that, yes, a lot of
boys do get in trouble from video games because
they're on it so much they, they're addicted
to it, and it pushes out everything else.
But a couple of hours a day for boys to be
in a group that's battling other boys, it
turns out that's actually a good thing, and
my son was somewhat cut off in sixth grade.
Tim Ferriss: Quick question.
Good, in what respects, how is that assessed?
Just in terms of acting as a release valve
for aggression or social cohesion?
Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
Yeah.
Group dynamics.
So, the release valve idea from Freud does
not end up being true.
Kids don't need to blow off aggression.
It's not like that.
It's rather that girls and boys each need
to practice their gendered behaviors.
This is what play is, it's play for all mammals,
is the way you practice in childhood the skills
you'll need as an adult.
And so boys and girls have very different
play.
Boys tend to break up into groups to compete
with other groups, and multiplayer video games
allow them to do that.
I'm not saying these are great.
I'm saying, ideally, the kid should be out
having adventures, but given that all the
kids are home, they're not allowed out until
they're 11, 12 years old.
So, at least a multiplayer video game allows
them to be part of a group.
Now, it's not a very creative group.
The rules are all set by the company.
It's not like video games are anywhere near
as good as being out on their own, but they're
not bad until it gets to be heavy.
That was a small mistake.
Once COVID hit, we did let him get Fortnite,
and then that was the only way he talked with
his friends.
So, that was okay.
The one mistake I think we did make was we
tried a few different summer camps.
We never quite found one, but I wish we'd
found a really good summer — and I would
urge this for everybody who's a parent of
young kids.
From the time your kid is about eight or nine,
certainly I'd say eight, find a sleep-away
camp that is pretty unstructured and unsupervised.
The kids have to have a lot of independence.
Some summer camps now are so over-protective.
You can't go to the bathroom unless you have
an escort.
And sometimes you need two escorts because
what if one escort falls down and gets hurt?
It's crazy, crazy overprotective everywhere.
But if you can find a summer camp that is
not crazy overprotective, send your kid there
every summer.
That, I think, is one of the few chances they
really have to develop skills to be out in
the woods.
So, I wish we'd done that.
Tim Ferriss: I was fortunate in that respect.
I got sent off to summer camps in Wyoming
where we would work on ranches, got kicked
by horses.
And I mean, I didn't suffer any terrible injuries,
but it wasn't free of injuries, but that was
okay.
Nothing was cataclysmic.
And that, I think, combined — I mean, I
don't have kids, but if I do, and I hope I
do at some point, I also think a year abroad
in a critical window similar to mine.
Because of that forced independence, and there
are other reasons, there are other compelling
reasons.
But I came back a fundamentally different
person in terms of my confidence in my abilities
to handle uncertainty and to adapt.
It was just night and day.
Complete face shift.
Jonathan Haidt: That's right.
That's how kids learn to manage risk for themselves.
You learn to be a risk taker.
When we overprotect kids, we're not doing
them any favors.
We're not keeping them safe.
We're increasing their odds of anxiety and
depression, self-harm and suicide.
And we're depriving them of the ability to
judge risks for themselves.
They're going to be less successful, less
likely to start businesses.
No, we've really messed up Gen Z.
Tim Ferriss: I feel like one other unexpected
blessing in my life was transitioning from
a very bad public school on Long Island to
a very good boarding school in New Hampshire,
which was actually largely my idea, encouraged
by teachers, a handful of good teachers, at
the pretty low quality public school on Long
Island, who effectively said, "You should
try to get out of here."
So I do owe them thanks.
When I went to the boarding school, which
was very similar to, let's say, a Dead Poets
Society type of setup, but classes six days
a week, mandatory sports.
And looking back, the mandatory sports, I
think, was the force multiplier that allowed
everything else to go more smoothly on so
many levels.
If I get to the point, and I hope I do, when
I'm parenting, I think physical activity in
group sports will probably play a compelling
role.
I don't know if there's any research to support
that, but —
Jonathan Haidt: Oh, there is.
There is.
But just two points.
I think you're basically right, but just two
points of nuance.
One is to the extent that it's heavily supervised
and there's a coach, it's less nutritious.
They're not going to learn as much.
The ideal is for kids to be out making up
their own games, enforcing the rules, because
then you have to keep the game going.
You have to learn how to adapt to other kids.
Whereas if there's a coach or a referee, then
what you learn is, "How do I get the referee
to come in on my side?"
And that's good preparation for college today
where if somebody says something, how do I
get a dean to punish him?
But that's bad preparation for life.
That's the first thing.
Second thing, so I just came across a finding
that participation in individualist sports,
like gymnastics and especially ballet, is
bad.
It actually is conducive to bad mental health.
I would never let my daughter do ballet.
But team sports where you're — soccer, basketball,
where you're really functioning as a team
over and over again, those have very good
effects on mental health and development.
So, I would agree with that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
My sport was wrestling, which was certainly
an individual sport, practiced in a team context.
You would have wrestling partners and so on.
I would have a child do wrestling, I think.
I'd have them wear headgear because I don't
think cauliflower ears work terribly well
for most people.
It goes doubly for females, I would say.
And if you haven't seen cauliflower on female
ears, I mean, it is scar tissue that will
not go away unless surgically removed.
Saw a lot of it in Japan in Judo players,
male and female, lots of cauliflowers.
But I found it to be, for me personally, at
least, an excellent venue for proving to myself
that I could exceed the limitations I thought
I had.
And in terms of work capacity and pain tolerance,
also.
I will say critical, critical components.
So I can't totally, with any conviction, say
that it was wrestling that did this, although
I have some belief that it contributed.
The coach, John Buxton, changed the lives
of almost every athlete he coached.
And to this day, I'm still close to him.
And many people in that wrestling team went
on to do some pretty outstanding things.
And they have all, to my knowledge, just about
all of them, have mentioned Mr. Buxton.
We have a tough time calling him —
Jonathan Haidt: I have to ask you a question
then.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Jonathan Haidt: A question.
Did he have a tough coaching style or did
he have a warm, nurturing style?
Tim Ferriss: He was extremely, extremely tough.
And this is what I was going to bring up.
He was extremely tough.
He did not suffer fools gladly at all.
If people complained about something, they
could fix themselves or should try to fix
themselves, he did not tolerate it.
He was a very tough coach, and he was a very,
very —
Jonathan Haidt: That's what I expected.
Tim Ferriss: And he was a very, very, very
good performer.
So, he himself had been an outstanding wrestler
and could go toe to toe with anyone in the
group, including people who went on to become
All Americans.
I mean, granted, in their particular corner
of the wrestling world and — exceptionally
tough.
And he would give occasional positive feedback.
And I don't want to say he was stingy, but
you've really had to earn it.
You really, really had to earn it.
Jonathan Haidt: Yes, that's what I figured
because wrestling is probably the best antifragile
sports there is, that is more than any other
sport.
Wrestling is really going to be about developing
your antifragility, your strength in the face
of adversity, testing your strength.
So the sport itself is very conducive to growth
in that way.
And I kind of knew, given how grateful you
were, I kind of knew that he was going to
be a tough coach, not a warm, nurturing coach.
Because you really need, to get the full benefit
of the growth into strength, you need someone
to push you.
You need someone with high standards.
You need someone to enforce those standards.
You need to strive for them.
A few years ago, when I gave a talk on The
Coddling of the American Mind, I was sitting
next to somebody who'd been, I think, the
head of the NCAA or high up in it, and this
was like 2018, 2019.
He said, "The tough coaching style — it's
not that it's banned, but that coaches are
fined and they can't use the tough style anymore
because the kids will cry, they'll report
them, they'll say, 'No, you need to be nurturing.'
And so tough coaching, I think, is going out
because what if you hurt a kid's feelings?"
And so in so many ways, we've accepted, and
that's a great untruth, number one, of The
Coddling of the American Mind is what doesn't
kill you makes you weaker.
Now, that's wrong.
That's a falsehood.
But that's what many people now believe.
And I think your experience really shows that
no, what doesn't kill you makes you stronger.
That's what you just said, and that's what
the psychology supports.
I think the lesson here for parents and teachers
is we need to have standards.
We need to push kids to meet the standards.
Sometimes the kids are not going to be happy.
And as long as we can be reported for pushing
the kids, we're not going to push the kids.
And the whole generation goes down the tubes.
So, that's what we're doing.
Tim Ferriss: And Coach Buxton also, I think,
fundamentally believed — I'll speak for
myself personally, I don't want to speak for
other folks, but he would reinforce the belief
that he saw in me the capacity to do more,
to perform better.
And it was in that context that being a tough
coach was the nice thing to do.
Does that make sense?
Jonathan Haidt: Yeah, absolutely.
Tim Ferriss: In service of realizing absolutely
that unrealized potential.
And I think all of the athletes he coached
felt that way, that he saw something in us
that we couldn't easily see.
And he was pushing us to unlock that potential.
And it was not abusive for the sake of, say,
breaking someone down, like perhaps a drill
sergeant might serve the function of shared
privation and that type of environment.
I think there's a purpose to that, and I think
it actually can be good for the collective.
But in this particular wrestling context,
the wellspring of the toughness came from
a place of, in some cases, explicitly saying,
"You can do better.
And I know you can do better."
And that was powerful.
It's very powerful.
Jonathan Haidt: And that is beautiful.
And I think what you've just done there is
you've stated what the telos of teaching should
be.
Telos is this Greek word that I'm very fond
of nowadays.
It means the end or purpose for which something
is done.
The telos of medicine is health.
What is the telos of a university?
And I've been focusing on the research aspect
where our telos is truth, but we're also teachers.
And our telos as teachers is not truth.
And I've been saying, "Oh, it's the education
of our kids.
It's learning, teaching."
But I think what you said is actually better.
The telos of a teacher is doing this service
of realizing their untapped potential.
That's what we're trying to do.
That's what we should be trying to do.
And we don't always do it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I've been very fortunate
in that respect to have had a handful of teachers
who were unrelenting in their pushing towards
the truth that they saw, which was their students
could in fact do the hard things.
And that was true.
I'll give thanks to another teacher, professor
Shimano, who was my first Japanese teacher.
And surprise, surprise, when I transferred
from Spanish to Japanese, I found Japanese
to be extremely difficult.
And I almost quit, I want to say, twice.
Once, just because of the difficulty with
the language grammatically.
And the second time when we started delving
into the various writing systems in Japanese,
and I was talked off the ledge by Professor
Shimano, who was able to just say, "Give it
some time.
I think you can do this.
And I'm betting that I can help you do this."
And good God, if I had not listened to that,
if I had pushed back, if I had become offended
and walked from that class, my life would
not be what it is today in any respect.
I feel very, very grateful.
Let's talk just a little bit, if there's anything
that you would care to add about intellectual
antifragility.
Are there other things that people can do,
other practices they can experiment with,
other resources that you would suggest they
look to develop intellectual antifragility?
Jonathan Haidt: Yes.
So, I created a resource, an online resource
with Caroline Mehl, who was working with me
originally at Heterodox Academy, but it branched
out.
If listeners go to ConstructiveDialogue.org,
we've created a program called Perspectives,
that kind of walks you through some of the
moral psychology, "Why are we like this?
Why are we so tribal?
Why do we have confirmation bias?"
And it teaches you it how to open your mind
and open your heart.
And it teaches you how to engage with people
and how to learn from them, how to listen.
All the things we've been talking about.
If you go to Constructive Dialogue, and yes,
dialogue is D-I-A-L-O-G-U-E.org.
We have a program that we created called Perspectives.
It used to be called Open Mind.
And if listeners go there, it was designed
for use in college courses, especially at
orientation, because if everyone in a group
has these concepts and they use these tools,
you're going to have great discussions.
You're going to be able to talk about hard
things.
It works really well in businesses as well.
So, that's one resource.
Another resource, I think, what I found really
helped me when I was writing The Righteous
Mind was I just subscribed to the best writing
on the other side.
I was very much on the Left when I started
the book, and I would read The New Republic
and The New York Times or things I read back
when The New Republic was a good magazine.
But I subscribed to National Review and The
Wall Street Journal.
And National Review has all these really smart
Center Right intellectuals, great writing.
And I would read about current events on the
Left and the Right.
I just understood things much better.
It's kind of trite, but you literally can't
understand something from looking at a single
perspective.
You kind of have to walk around it and look
at it from all sides.
So, resources are out there, and the internet
is such that it will guide you to fantastic
resources from each perspective.
And if you don't seek them out, then what
you get, if you're on the Left, you do encounter
some Conservative ideas, but usually you encounter
reports of them in their worst form or reports
to them being held up to ridicule.
And same thing if you're on the right.
Yeah, if you want to be smarter and stronger,
you must seek out different perspectives.
It's kind of trite, but there it is.
Tim Ferriss: So, ConstructiveDialogue.org.
We'll link to all of these in the show notes.
And I'll also create a URL by the time this
comes up, it'll work, which will just be tim.blog/haidt,
H-A-I-D-T, and that will forward to this episode,
so people can find all the links in the show
notes really easily.
Let me ask you the billboard question.
I'm curious what your take on this might be.
The billboard question is sometimes a dead
end, and I'll take full blame for that if
it is.
But if you could put a message, a quote, anything
at all on a billboard, metaphorically speaking,
to get something out to billions of people,
assuming they would all understand it, what
might you put on that billboard?
Jonathan Haidt: Ah, that's actually easy.
Actually, I'm going to nominate two.
If you'll give me the front and the back of
the billboard.
Tim Ferriss: I'll give you two.
Jonathan Haidt: Okay.
The first is a quote from a Zen Buddhist philosopher
in the eighth century, Seng-ts'an was his
name, Chinese Buddhist philosopher.
And I've used this quote in most of my books.
I'll just read the whole thing.
He says,
"The Perfect Way is only difficult for those
who pick and choose;
Do not like, do not dislike; all will then
be clear.
Make a hairbreadth difference, and Heaven
and Earth are set apart;
If you want the truth to stand clear before
you, never be for or against.
The struggle between 'for' and 'against' is
the mind's worst disease."
This is what we were talking about before,
about getting beyond moralism.
When you're moralistic, when you're judging,
when you're saying, "This is good, this is
bad," you get stupider.
You don't understand the nuance of things.
This quote is about sort of demoralization,
not like being demoralized, but sucking the
moralism or the morality out of something
and just trying to understand it.
That's the first.
And then if I have the back of the billboard,
I would put this quote from Joseph Campbell.
So, Joseph Campbell was a professor at, I
think, it was Bryn Mawr or Sarah Lawrence
rather, in the late 20th century.
He studied myths.
And there was a wonderful PBS series on, I
think, The Hero with a Thousand Faces was
one of his books.
And so Campbell, this motto, this really calms
me because I'm very alarmed at the way things
are going, the way our complex dynamical system
is kind of veering into chaos.
And I found this quote to be really, really
comforting, and I sort of have it up on my
walls, various places.
He says the lesson from his studying of heroes,
myths, heroes journey stories around the world
is this, "Participate joyfully in the sorrows
of the world.
We cannot cure the world of sorrows, but we
can choose to live in joy.
The warrior's approach is to say yes to life,
yes to it all."
That's what I'd put up.
Tim Ferriss: Love it.
That's a great combination.
And you mentioned Buddhism and Stoicism earlier.
I don't know if you feel this way, but I have
felt over time that there is tremendous overlap
in those two, let's just call it lineages,
or broadly speaking schools of thought.
And I suppose both are also related to your
front and back of the billboard in the sense
of cultivating equanimity, a sense of being
unperturbed by the vicissitudes, if I could
use a fancy word, of life, the daily flux,
all of these tiny and large tragedies that
befall everyone at various points.
How do you revisit some of these practical
philosophies for yourself?
Let's just say that you're going through a
period or there's an event where you start
to feel dysregulated, consumed by emotions,
what do you do?
Jonathan Haidt: Oh, yeah.
Thank you for that.
Earlier you asked me, do I have practices?
There was the summer of 2017, I think it was,
when Trump was threatening nuclear war against
— there was a possibility of nuclear war
with North Korea.
And I really thought, "I think he might actually
want to do it."
And I was really thinking, "This really could
be the end of the world."
And it was then that I started rereading Stoic
writings in the morning.
And my favorite two are Marcus Aurelius' Meditations,
the Gregory Hays translation is, I think,
the best one.
And then also Epictetus, his collected works.
And what I do whenever I read, I do all my
reading electronically now, because I like
to copy out text.
So I copy my favorite lines out into an Evernote
file.
And so what I do in the mornings, I don't
even have it in my calendar, "Let me see,
how do I record in my calendar..."
Every day repeating, there's a couple different
things I do, but it's basically either reading
Stoicism or Buddhism or reflecting on psychotherapy.
I've been in therapy for a while.
So, yes, and I have it right here.
Stoic or Buddhists reading, and I have to
check it off each morning.
And I do that before I check email, before
anything else.
And right, you're right.
Stoicism and Buddhism, they're very, very
similar.
Except Stoicism is sort of a Western version
because it is more about action in the world.
Now, Buddhism, there are Buddhisms that are
very much in the world, there are those that
pull you away more.
But there is a sort of an Eastern sensibility
in Daoism about, "Don't do anything, just
settle.
Just let the world arrange itself."
And Westerners are not like that and Stoics
are not like that, but it is like act in the
world, "Okay, you're the emperor of Rome,
but you're still getting upset about things
and you have to — everything's crazy around
you."
But it's not just for emperors.
Epictetus was a slave.
And so it actually works at any level of society.
You can never control everything, even if
you're the emperor.
Both of them are just incredibly psychologically
wise ways of living in a world that you can't
control and maintaining not just your equanimity,
but even the capacity to be openhearted and
loving.
There's very similar passages not about necessarily
loving your enemies, but actually sometimes
it is like, and they both use the same technique
of saying, "And remember, you'll both be dead
before long."
That's a quote from The Dhammapada, "How can
you quarrel, knowing that you'll both be dead
before long?"
It's all trivial.
Tim Ferriss: How long is your document that
you review in the morning, that Evernote file?
Jonathan Haidt: Well, I've got a whole big
one for Seneca, who I'm going through Seneca.
There's just so much writing and it's not
as dense in terms of gems, but I've got one
for Epictetus, one for Aurelius, one for Buddha.
You know what, if you go to the coddling.com,
which is the webpage for The Coddling of the
American Mind, and you go to Solutions, Better
Mental Health, I've actually put up at the
bottom, I've put up a collection of sayings
by Marcus Aurelius that basically are about
the three great untruths of the book.
So, here's one.
"Today I escaped from anxiety, or no, I discarded
it because it was within me in my own perceptions,
not outside."
This is the great untruth that we cover in
the book is always trust your feelings.
But what the Buddhists and the Stoics and
CBT tell us is, "No, don't always trust your
feelings.
Question them.
Sometimes they're legitimate, but sometimes
they're gross overreactions to nothing."
Anyway, yeah, those are the great wisdom traditions
in my opinion.
Tim Ferriss: How long do you spend in the
morning, if you check the box of that calendar
reminder with that reading?
Jonathan Haidt: Oh, it's about 10 minutes.
Tim Ferriss: 10 minutes.
Jonathan Haidt: Recently, I'm doing a loving-kindness
meditation because I'm very cerebral and I
actually sort of need to open my heart more.
But I make sort of a coffee substitute.
I'm very sensitive to caffeine, so I'm experimenting
with these mushroom-based things.
Anyway, but I make a hot beverage and then
I sit on a comfortable sofa and just about
10 minutes, because what I found is that my
MBA students, I asked, "How many of you check
your phone before you get up to pee?
And how many of you wait until you actually
have gone into the bathroom?"
And very few of them wait.
It's like right away.
Okay, turn on the stream.
Turn on the stream, have it come in.
No, don't do that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, have a better boot up sequence
for your morning and day.
Jonathan Haidt: Exactly.
That's right.
Tim Ferriss: Jon, I really appreciate all
the time.
This has been a lot of fun.
I've copious notes.
There are many things that I'm going to be
looking up, and I think the first will be
On Liberty Chapter Two.
I'm going to check in and give that a read.
And then I have many others.
Is there anything else that you would like
to say?
Any closing comments, any questions, anything
you'd like to point my audience to that we
haven't mentioned or that we have mentioned?
Any complaints you'd like to lodge?
Anything at all?
Jonathan Haidt: Yeah.
No, I'd just like to say, my mission when
I moved to Stern Business School, everyone
has a mission statement.
I made a mission statement, and my mission
is to use my research and that of others in
moral psychology to help important institutions
work better.
And I've started various organizations.
So, if you're concerned about universities,
please go to HeterodoxAcademy.org and join
if you're an academic or support us financially,
if you can.
If you're concerned about people's ability
to talk to each other or you need to address
conflict in your own organization, please
go to ConstructiveDialogue.org.
If you are a parent and you have kids born
after 1996, you have Gen Z kids, please go
to LetGrow.org.
A site I started with Lenore Skenazy to encourage
free range parenting.
And so, all three of those are nonprofit foundations.
We really need help.
I'm trying hard to raise money for them.
So, please support us.
And all of them, I hope, will help you solve
problems in your own lives and in your own
organizations and your own families.
Tim Ferriss: Perfect.
That's the perfect place to wrap up.
And for everyone listening, all of these links
I will gather and put also in the show notes
so they'll be collected in one place and you
can click them to take yourself to all these
destinations.
tim.blog/Haidt, H-A-I-D-T.
On Twitter, be careful, it's a full contact
sport out there, @JonHaidt, and JonathanHaidt.com.
Jon, thank you so much for taking the time
and being so game.
I really appreciate it.
Jonathan Haidt: Tim, thank you.
This was rollicking and good fun.
Tim Ferriss: And to everybody out there, be
just a little kinder than is necessary.
Don't believe everything that you think.
Ask questions before you make strong statements.
And thanks for listening.